- [Sal] Hi this is Sal and
I'm here with Jeffrey Rosen
who's the head of the
National Constitution Center
in Philadelphia.
In the first video we did an overview
of the entire Article
Two of the Constitution
which covers the powers of the presidency,
and now we're gonna jump
in a little bit deeper.
Jeffrey one of the things
that surprises me about
Article Two is for a job as
important as the President,
it's an awfully short amount of text.
- [Jeffrey] It is.
Article One, defining the powers
of Congress is much longer.
The Framers were much more
concerned about tyranny
in Congress than tyranny in the Executive,
and because there is so much
wiggle room in Article Two,
presidential practice has
been really important,
and obviously the most important
president in establishing
that practice was our first
president, George Washington.
- [Sal] This is this idea
that because it was short
it left out a lot of what
a president maybe could do
or could not do and that's
why our first president,
the precedent that he
set was really important
for how people perceived
the powers of the President.
- [Jeffrey] Yes, it's a nice homonym,
he was a both a president and
set this important precedent
and because the Framers knew
that Washington was gonna be
the first president, he
takes office in 1789,
right when the Constitution is ratified,
they trusted him to
establish these precedents
which have been followed to this day.
- [Sal] And just a little
bit of historical context,
in 1776 is the official
founding of the country,
the Declaration of Independence,
the official start of
the Revolutionary War.
Although I'm sure you have
skirmishes before that.
Then we have the Articles of Confederation
that get ratified in 1781.
It was deemed that it was too weak,
essentially of a confederation and then
our Constitution gets ratified 1789,
same year that Washington takes office
as our first president.
- [Jeffrey] Exactly right.
As soon as he takes office,
Washington faces this dilemma
that's not answered by the Constitution.
And that's does he recognize
the French Revolution
who have just killed and
guillotined Louis XIV.
So Washington has these three choices,
he can stand by the monarchy
and condemn the Revolution,
he can recognize the French
Revolutionaries as the
rightful government or he
can say it's not my choice
and all of our former treaties are void.
He consults his cabinet,
decides to recognize
the Revolutionaries and that
establishes the precedent
that Presidents now have
unilateral power to recognize
or de-recognize foreign governments.
- [Sal] And that's interesting
'cause when we're looking at
Section Two which at least
talks something about treaties,
it says that the President
can make treaties,
I'll underline this.
The President can make
treaties provided two thirds
of the Senators present concur.
It talks about ambassadors
but it doesn't talk about
the recognition of foreign countries.
And as you point out
the French Revolution,
things started in 1789, as
you get into the early 90's
the Revolution continues
and Washington says well,
do we recognize the
government of Louis the XVI
that helped America during
the French Revolution
or do we recognize the
Revolutionaries who seem
to have a lot more in common
with us in terms of their
principles around government,
at least of the stated ones.
And he decides that
well, it's not written in
the Constitution here but as President,
I can make that decision to
recongize the Revolutionaries.
- [Jeffrey] Absolutely.
That leads to another series
of important questions
which you just flagged, who exactly gets
to negotiate the treaties.
And Washington has, soon
after the French Revolutionary
recognition, he wants to
negotiate a treaty with Britain,
it's called the Jay Treaty.
So he secretly sends Gouverneur Morris,
who's the Framer who
is most responsible for
drafting the Preamble to the Constitution,
as an unofficial emissary
or negotiator to Britain
and they negotiate the
treaty and then Washington
designates John Jay as the envoy.
The Senate doesn't endorse
the diplomatic mission,
Jay is getting his orders
straight from Washington.
After the deal is reached,
then Congress, after the fact,
approves of Washington's
diplomatic entrepreneurship.
So this establishes the
really important precedent
that the President can send
emissaries to negotiate
treaties which are approved by Congress
after the fact, and that
precedent is seized on by
President Thomas Jefferson
who negotiated for
the really important purchase
of the Louisiana Territory
on the spot without Congressional approval
and gets Senate approval after the fact.
- [Sal] Famously negotiated
with Napoleon Bonaparte
because he frankly, his navy
had been destroyed at Trafalgar
so he was in no position to
protect something halfway
across the world (laughing).
- [Jeffrey] And this drove
Jefferson's critics crazy
'cause Jefferson is this big proponent,
before he becomes President,
of limited Presidential
authority and he becomes
President and he seems
to expand it by seizing on
this treaty negotiation power
that isn't explicitly in the Constitution
and hugely increases the
landmass of the United States.
- [Sal] And the importance
of these precedents,
just to go back to
Section Two, it does say,
"He shall have power
by and with the advice
"and consent of the
Senate to make treaties,
"provided two thirds of the
Senators present concur."
And your point is that the way
it's written in Section Two,
it's not clear whether you need the advice
and consent beforehand
or whether they just
kind of approve after the fact.
Washington, his term was
from 1789 until 1797,
he assumed that no, I should be able to go
and very nimbly negotiate
these things without
having to involve the entire Senate.
And once it's negotiated
I need to go to them
and get them to approve it.
Jefferson, who was in
power from 1801 to 1809,
kind of further reinforced that precedent,
said hey, I'm just gonna
negotiate this thing
and then get it approved.
- [Jeffrey] That's exactly
right and that allows Jefferson,
when he gets approval for the
Louisiana Purchase in 1803,
to get the Senate to
approve the treaty and
to persuade the House to
finance the legal structure
for the new territory.
He probably couldn't have
done that if he hadn't
worked out the negotiating
details in advance.
- [Sal] Another element that
the second paragraph here
of Section Two talks about is,
with the advice and consent
of the Senate, this is talked about a lot.
The Constitution tries
to set up the Senate
as where the President
goes to test his ideas,
get some thinking.
But Washington also decides that well,
it's not that efficient
to talking to all these
elected officials, maybe
I'll set my own body
that I talk to more frequently.
- [Jeffrey] That's exactly right.
As we talked about before,
Section Three of the Constitution
seems to say that the
President can consult Congress
for advice in all sorts of situations.
He can convene both houses.
He can adjourn them and so forth,
but Washington established this precedent
of using a cabinet, and that's a term that
doesn't appear anywhere
in the Constitution.
Despite the part of the
Constitution that also allows
the President to seek the
opinions of the various officers,
Washington informally
sought his cabinet's advice.
And today although the
cabinet meets less frequently
than it did before, the
Presidential Cabinet
or Cabinet meetings is
established as a precedent
in the Executive Branch.
- [Sal] The last piece
that this Section Two also
talks about the ability of the President
to make appointments,
anything from ambassadors,
other public ministers,
consuls, judges, Supreme Court,
and other officers of the
United States and it also talks
about Inferior Officers which
are more junior officers
that some Presidents can do that without
getting approved by Congress.
This is also up for some interpretation
and Washington's precedent's
important there as well.
- [Jeffrey] It is, Washington
was very frustrated by
the Senate and basically
decided to cut it out and
not to seek advice and consent in person.
One account says that when
he left the Senate Chamber,
he said he'd be damned if
he ever went there again.
He didn't seek the Senate's
written advice before making
big decisions like treaty
negotiations and he just
preferred to consult the Cabinet.
That Cabinet had huge and
important disagreements.
Again we know from the musical Hamilton,
Hamilton and Jefferson disagree about
the constitutionality of the
Bank of the United States,
they both give their opinions,
Washington listens to both
and he sides with Hamilton
over Jefferson and decides to
bless the constitutionality
of the bank, he got that from his Cabinet
and not from Congress.
- [Sal] And then finally
in this appointment,
to what degree can the
President unilaterally
take people out of
their jobs, fire people,
that is also left to interpretation.
- [Jeffrey] That's right,
Washington established the ability
for President unilaterally
to fire executive officers
or executive department heads.
Since the Senate textually
has the power to hire
department heads, you
could have read Article Two
to allow it to have a mirror
role in firing them as well
but the Supreme Court blessed
this idea that the President
can dismiss people on his own,
there was an important case
called Meyers Against United
States which said that
the Vesting Clause which
we talked about earlier
gave the President both the
authority to execute the law
and to remove executive officials.
There are other cases like
the Humphrey's Executor case
from 1935 which said
that Congress could limit
the President's ability to
remove certain commissioners.
But the broad precedent
that Washington established
is that the President's unitary authority
allows him alone to fire
Executive Branch officials.
- [Sal] Fascinating, well
thanks so much Jeffrey,
this is super valuable.
- [Jeffrey] Thanks, great to talk.